[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo da sind wir wieder Mirko Kasimir
und Natalie Strauß und das hier ist eine
neue Ausgabe von Tatort Deutschland
heute ziehen wir uns die Wanderschuhe an
und machen uns auf den Weg in die
Appalachen das ist ein Gebirgszug im
Osten der USA durch dieses Gebirge zieht
sich der Appalachian Trail der längste
durchgängige Wanderweg der Welt
3540 km zwischen Springer mountain in
Georgia und Mount Katar den in Maine
tausende versuchen Jahr für Jahr die
gesamte Strecke in 5 bis 7 Monaten
zurückzulegen doch nur wenige von ihnen
schaffen es
1981 ist einer von ihnen ein junger Mann
namens Robert Mount von Junior und er
wird es nicht schaffen
robert hat große Pläne der Trip in die
Appalachen ist kein Urlaub oder an
Selbstfindungstrip naja zumindest nicht
nur er arbeitet als Sozialarbeiter in
einem Heim für geistig behinderte Kinder
in Main und will mit seiner
spektakulären Wanderung Spenden für das
Heim einwerben und auf die Situation
seiner Schützlinge aufmerksam machen ich
habe ein Foto von ihm gefunden und wenn
man sich das anschaut naja also er
könnte auch der Star aus irgendeiner
80er Fernsehserie sein ja stimmt Bart
und Frisur sind wirklich schon sehr Toms
mäßig ich habe das Foto auch gesehen
gleich daneben ist das Foto von Susan
Ramsey auch sie ist 27 Jahre alt genau
wie Robert sie lächelt sehr verschmitzt
und unheimlich sympathisch in die Kamera
ein bisschen als ob sie gerade bei etwas
verboten immer erwischt wurde verboten
im Sinne von du sollst nicht vom
Kuchenteig naschen
ihre schwarzen Haare sind zu dicken
Zöpfen geflochten Susan ist eine
Kollegin von Robert und sie hat sich
zwei Wochen Urlaub genommen um ihnen ein
Stück des langen Weges zu begleiten und
zu sonst letzten Tag vor der Rückreise
nach Maine sind die beiden mit einer
weiteren Wanderin verabredet doch sie
erscheinen nicht an dem Treffpunkt die
Frau macht sich ganz klar sorgen das
kann da nicht alles passiert sein sie
könnten einen Hang hinabgestürzt und
verletzt sein und hat es da nicht auch
schon Berichte über bärenangriffe
gegeben sie informiert die Behörden Tom
Lawson stellvertretender Sheriff von
Charles County macht sich mit ein paar
Polizisten auf um Wanderer nach den
beiden Vermissten zu befragen einer will
sie zusammen mit einem seltsamen Mann
gesehen haben auch in einem kleinen
Dorfladen hat man sie gesehen dort
erzählt auch jemand den Ermittlerin dass
ein seltsamer Mann herumliefere und
behaupte er wisse was mit den wandern
geschehen ist als Larsen nachfragt wer
das denn sei ach winken die
Einheimischen direkt ab ach das ist nur
der lügende der erzählt den ganzen Tag
Unsinn und denkt sich die fantastischen
Geschichten aus vergessen Sie es einfach
und Tom Lawson vergisst es er und seine
Männer schwärmen weiter auf den
Appalachian Trail aus und befragen
Wanderer zwei von ihnen geben an die
beiden zusammen mit einem weiteren Mann
der sich unheimlich Verhalten habe in
der Nähe des Wapiti Shelter gesehen zu
haben das ist eine kleine Blockhütte am
Trail eine von vielen Unterkünften für
Wanderer auf der Strecke als lassen die
Hütte untersucht sind bereits 11 Tage
vergangen seit Susan und rubber zuletzt
Leben gesehen wurden zuerst scheint
alles normal zu sein doch dann fällt
Lawson auf dass der Fußboden merkwürdig
aussieht ich sah aus als wäre irgendwas
zwischen den Dielen runtergelaufen
erinnert er sich später also fahre ich
mit meinem Messer zwischen die Bretter
es war eine dicke und rote Substanz dort
unten ich sagte ich glaube hier ist Blut
die Polizisten suchen das Gelände um die
Blockhütte ab auf einer kleinen offenen
Fläche ein paar Meter weiter abseits
bemerken sie einen Haufen Blätter sie
beginnt zu graben und finden einen
stoffschlafsack und im Schlafsack die
Leiche von Susan Ramsay am nächsten Tag
trifft ein Leichen Spürhund ein ein paar
hundert Meter weiter schnüffelt er an
einem Baumstumpf und setzt sich hin
wieder beginnen die Beamten zu graben
und finden noch einen Schlafsack und
noch eine Leiche Robert mountford Junior
Robert wurde in den Kopf geschossen er
muss das erste Opfer gewesen sein hat
abwehrverletzung an den Händen und ein
Dutzend Stichwunden die von einem langen
Nagel und im Messer stammen außerdem
schwere Kopfverletzungen die von
Schlägen mit einem eisernen Gegenstand
stammen am Tatort finden die am
mittleren diesem Buch und darin einen
blutigen Fingerabdruck der nicht von
Susan stammt sondern vom Mörder Randall
Eve Fall gelöst aber wie würden hier
nicht davon erzählen wenn die Geschichte
damit Ende wäre erzähl uns mal von
Randes Smith Mirko Randall lies Smith
wird am 29 Juni 1953 in Paris Birk
Virginia geboren er ist das einzige Kind
von Lorettas Smith die ihn allein
aufzieht Nachbarn erzählen dass sie und
ihr Sohn sehr zurückgezogen leben und
mit niemandem reden an der Schule bleibt
Randall ein Einzelgänger wenn er mit
anderen redet fühlen Sie sich schnell
von ihm abgestoßen denn Randall ist ein
gewohnheitsmäßiger Lügner die
Schulkameraden geben ihm den Spitznamen
na ihr ahnt es vielleicht schon
der Spitzname eines Mannes der 1981
herum erzählen wird er wisse was mit den
Vermissten wandern geschehen sei
Randall hat doch während der Highschools
Zeit keine Freunde und erst recht keine
Freundin und da gehen bei mir schon die
ersten bahnleuchten an zumal er auch
nach der schularbeiter bei seiner Mutter
wohnt manchmal verschwindet er für viele
Tage um auf den Trail zu wandern da aber
keine sozialen Kontakte hat vermisst ihr
noch niemand sein Geld verdient damit so
kleinen Gelegenheits Minijobs meine Zeit
lang Job der auf der Norfolk Werft in
Newport die Aufträge für die US Navi
erfüllt und jeder der dort arbeitet muss
seine Fingerabdrücke abgeben so
gelangweiler Smith in die Datenbank die
die Ermittler zu ihm führt
okay wir haben da jetzt diesen creepy
Typen der keine Freunde hat bei seiner
Mutter wohnt
gewohnheitsmäßig lügt und offenbar zwei
Menschen ermordet hat aber noch ist er
nicht gefasst bei ihm zu Hause finden
die ja Mittler gestohlene
krankenhausinstrumente die zu
Sexspielzeug umgebaut wurden so Tom
Lawson
definitiv niemand dem ich auf einem
Wanderweg begegnen will sie finden auch
eine blutgetränkte Jeans und persönliche
Gegenstände seiner Opfer und hiermit
wird der Verdacht so Gewissheit Ende
Juni kann er in Mörtel Beach South
Carolina endlich gefasst werden am
Vorabend des Prozesses bekennt sich
Smith schuldig er wird wegen zweifachen
Mordes zu 30 Jahren Haft verurteilt ein
Urteil das viele für mich halten aber
immerhin 30 Jahre sind 30 Jahren den er
für seine tatüsst und keine Gefahr für
die Öffentlichkeit darstellt ja finde
ich das trifft es eigentlich ganz gut 30
Jahre sind 30 Jahre nur dass es im Fall
von Randall Lee Smith nur 15 Jahre sind
was
1996 kommt der auf Bewährung frei er Kid
ins Haus seiner Mutter zurück und das
ist schon bemerkenswert die Jahre im
Gefängnis sind die einzige Zeit in der
er nicht bei seiner Mutter lebte er
verrichtet Gelegenheitsjobs und nimmt
seine Wanderung auf der mapperlädchen
Trail wieder auf sein einziger Begleiter
und Freund ist ein Hund Smith wird
endgültig zum Einsiedler und sieht auch
so aus er magert ab und geht gebückt die
Zeit in den Bergen zehrt ihn aus
2008 seine Mutter ist da schon einige
Jahre tot verschwindet er endgültig in
den Wald Nachbarn fällt auf dass deine
Post seit mehreren Wochen nicht gelehrt
wurde und alarmieren die Behörden und
die beginnen sofort mit einer groß
angelegten suche unter anderem werden
Plakate aufgehängt wenn ein Mörder auf
Bewährung verschwindet dann möchte man
schon gerne wissen wohin und warum im
übrigen wird immer gesucht wenn jemand
auf dem Trail verschwindet einfach weil
es sein kann dass er sich den Knöchel
gebrochen hat und jetzt und wo liegt und
dringend Hilfe braucht aber Randal Smith
braucht keine Hilfe nee sicher nicht
oder höchstens in dem Sinne dass er
schon als Kind Hilfe gebraucht hätte
vielleicht von jemandem wie Robert
mountford dem Sozialarbeiter den
erschossen hat naja und er braucht etwas
zu essen aber dazu kommen wir gleich
Natalie erzähl uns doch mal von Scott
jonsten und Sean Farmer die beiden sind
Freunde 38 und 33 Jahre alt und am 6 mai
2018 zu einem Angeltrip in die
Appalachen verabredet eine Tradition
seit den Tagen ihrer Kindheit
Scott Johnson ist bereits am Morgen
aufgebrochen und hat in einem
Bachforellen geangelt und zwar sehr
erfolgreich er setzt sich mit dem Fangen
in seinen Truck um an die Stelle zu
fahren wo er und jean-pharma ihre Zelte
aufschlagen wollen
unterwegs begegnet er einem seltsamen
Mann naja ihr ahnt sich ja schon wer das
ist aber Scott hat keine Ahnung und
erzählt später eigentlich habe ich
zuerst den Hund gesehen ein räudiger
Hund man konnte seine Rippen sehen der
Hund war am Verhungern auch der Mann
sieht hungrig aus und abgemagert Gott
hält an die beiden unterhalten sich der
Fremde behauptet er habe geangelt aber
im Bach gebe es keine Fische es gott
schaut ihn verwundert an und öffne die
Kiste mit den Forellen wahrscheinlich
hast du eine schlechte Stelle erwischt
tröstet er und schenkt ihm ein paar von
seinen Fischen der Fremde fragt Gott wo
er sein Lager aufgeschlagen habe der
erzählt ihm von seinem Freund Shawn und
zeigt in die Richtung ihres Zeltplatzes
der Mann nickt mein Zelt ist auch in der
Richtung war etwas weiter vielleicht
komme ich auf dem Rückweg bei euch
vorbei die beiden Freunde treffen sich
wie verabredet und bald taucht dieser
abgemagerte fremde aus und
stellt sich als Ricky Smith vor sie
unterhalten sich freundlich und
irgendwann beschließen Chance und Scott
wohl mehr aus Mitleid als aus
Begeisterung über diesen neuen Bekannten
ihn zum Abendessen einzuladen bald
brutzeln die Forellen über dem
Lagerfeuer ich habe sogar eine extra
Forelle für den Hund gegrillt erinnert
sich Gott aber naja ihr kennt das
vielleicht das Gute an Gästen und ganz
besonders an Überraschungsgästen ist
dass sie irgendwann wieder gehen
Ricky wie sich der Mann nennt macht aber
überhaupt gar keine Anstalten zu seinem
eigenen Zelt zurückzukehren er erzählt
den beiden langen und breit über sein
Leben natürlich sind die Geschichten
alle erstungen und erlogen aber das
Wissen Scott und schauen ja zu diesem
Zeitpunkt nicht als die Dämmerung
einsetzt beginnen sich die beiden
Freunde zu sorgen der Mann ist in keiner
guten Verfassung und wenn er nicht bald
aufbricht muss er im Dunkeln zu seinem
Zelt laufen und es ist so schon verdammt
leicht zu stolpern
sie drängen ihn freundlich zum Aufbruch
und endlich erhebt er sich und winkt
seinem Hund komm junge sagte er dann
greift er in die Tasche seiner Tarnjacke
sieht ganz beiläufig eine 22er heraus
und schießt schon in die Schläfe bevor
Scott reagieren kann dreht sich der
Fremde um und schießt ihn in den Hals
dann dreht er sich wieder Zuschauer
Farmer der trotz seines kopfschusses
noch immer steht und schießt ihm in die
Brust
zusammen Gott rennt in Richtung des
Waldrandes um sich zu verstecken während
das Blut aus der Wunde in seinem Hals
sprudelt Ricky schießt noch einmal und
trifft ihn in den Rücken während Gott
Flucht den Schützen abgelenkt hat kann
schon zu seinem trucken der noch
ungefähr fünf Meter entfernt steht
unglaublich nach einem Schuss in die
Schläfe und einem in die Brust er
schafft es hinein aus dem Fahrersitz
fragt sich was mit seinem Freund
passiert ist aber ihm helfen kann
entscheidet sich zur Flucht und starte
den Wagen da taucht das Gesicht des
Mörders neben der Seitenscheibe auf
er hebt die Waffe richtet sie direkt auf
Chance Kopf und drückt ab das Magazin
ist leer schauen wartet nicht bis der
andere nachgeladen hat sondern drückt
das Gaspedal durch und rast los nach ein
paar Metern stoppt er aus dem Wald
taumelt der ebenfalls schwerverletztes
Gott das ist doch unvorstellbar beide
sind in die Brust getroffen Scott auf
dem Beifahrersitz hat einen Finger in
das Loch in seinen Hals gesteckt um die
Blutung zu stoppen und schon längst nach
einem Kopfschuss sein pickup truck in
die kurvige enge Straße aus den Bergen
herunter und darf sich überhaupt gar
keine Fehler erlauben neben der Straße
geht es mehrere Meter in die Tiefe
vorsichtig zu fahren kommt aber nicht in
Frage wer weiß wie lange sie noch bei
Bewusstsein bleiben können und Scott
steht noch bei den selten und der
Schlüssel steckt es wäre für den Täter
also ein Leichtes sie zu verfolgen
die beiden schaffen es zurück in die
Zivilisation lebend
sie klopfen beim ersten Haus mit der
leuchteten Fenster dass sie finden
können die Bewohner alarmieren Polizei
und Notdienst und leisten Erste Hilfe
obwohl es eine ganze Weile dauert bis
die Polizei eintrifft schaffen es Schorn
und Gott bei Bewusstsein zu bleiben und
Sie können sogar eine Aussage machen und
den Täter beschreiben diese Beschreibung
veranlasst die Polizisten Ihnen das Foto
zu zeigen mit dem nach Randall Lee Smith
gesucht wird die beiden nicken ihr ricky
ist der Randall der schon einmal auf den
appellagen Trail getötet hat 27 Jahre
zuvor und nicht weit entfernt von der
Stelle an der die beiden Freunde einen
unbeschwerten Ausflug genießen wollten
schauen uns Gott überleben diese
schrecklichste Nacht ihres Lebens die
Polizei sucht nach randallies mit nun
wegen versuchten Mordes aber sie muss
gar nicht lang suchen Smith ist in Scott
Pickup von Tatort geflohen und ein stay
Trooper entdeckt später das Fahrzeug
nach einer kurzen Verfolgungsjagd kommst
du mit von der Straße ab der Pickup
überschlägt sich
da er sich bei dem Unfall verletzt hat
kommt mir für zwei Tage ins Krankenhaus
am 9 mai wird er schließlich in die
medizinische Abteilung eines
regionalgefängnisses überstellt
am Abend des 10 Mai will ein Gefängnis
Beamter Smith das Abendessen bringen
doch der Gefangene kommt nicht zur
Zellentür um es in Empfang zu nehmen der
Beamte ruft seinen Namen mehrmals doch
es kommt keine Antwort als er die Tür
öffnet findet man es Smith bewusstlos
kurz darauf ist Randall Lee Smith tot er
wurde 54 Jahre alt
die Todesursache können nie ganz sicher
geklärt werden vermutlich eine
Nachwirkung des Unfalls eine Thrombose
oder dergleichen es gibt aber noch zwei
gute Nachrichten schauen uns Gott
konnten schon nach einer Woche aus dem
Krankenhaus entlassen werden sie hatten
irrsinniges Glück sie werden tot wenn
die Kugel sie nur wenige Millimeter
weiter links oder rechts getroffen
hätten sie fahren immer noch zum Angeln
in die Berge und schlagen ihr Zelt an
derselben Stelle auf an der sie im Mai
2008 fast gestorben werden Natalie du
hast zwei gute Nachrichten versprochen
oh ja stimmt randals einziger und an
seinen Verbrechen vollkommen
unschuldiger Freund sein Hund wurde
adoptiert und konnte den Rest seines
Lebens ohne Hunger bei einer liebevollen
Pflegefamilie verbringen
und damit sind wir am Ende der heutigen
Episode angelangt wir danken euch dass
ihr wieder dabei wart wir haben die
Geschichte des Appalachian trailkillers
anhand verschiedener Quellen erzählt
besonders hilfreich waren die beiden
sehr umfangreichen Beiträge Blatt on the
mountain und lonely dark and deep der
Washington Post sowie escape from brushy
Mountain auf NBC news.com wenn ihr
Anregungen Kritik oder fallvorschläge
für uns habt dann schreibt uns gern bei
Instagram oder eine Mail die Links dazu
findet ihr in den shonouts vielen Dank
fürs zuhören und bis bald euer Mirko und
eure Natalie